this episode is presented by ikea
[Music]
a hero can come from anywhere
manhattan
brooklyn
even other parts of new york city where
you from
greece but now the mcu asks you to
imagine the impossible
could anything good come from jersey
yeah buddy time to gt triple l gym tan
lay my life on the line for you bunnies
let me slam a hoagie and take a shidoobi
first though
miss
marvel iman vilani stars as kamala khan
the first pakistani american in the mcu
to not play an indian guy i
when a magic bracelet unlocks her inner
mario maker
she'll join the mcu's next wave of cool
female heroes who have to carry the
heavy burden of standing for captain
marvel i know some of you think well she
abandoned the people of earth but like
look it's it's not true can a woman just
live oh so that's where her stretching
powers went carol damer's went away
she'd punch a hole in space and time and
she'd help them now yeah and then she'd
blow up your brother's wedding in a red
sox jersey
kamala must learn to come out of her
shell at school and learn to be proud of
who she is which he'll accomplish after
one episode
then spend the rest of the time running
from damage control the department
disney activates when shuri posts an
anti-vaxx video i mean the group
responsible for controlling all the
damage that they themselves create they
already blew up my apartment
they're all locked into battle against
the clandestines exiles who want to
return to their world even though it's
made of glass shards it turns you into a
spooky skeleton
gives your only son a cosmic tummy ache
not a great plan
but kamala won't face another poorly
developed marvel villain alone she's got
three helpers spread evenly across the
kind geek to questionable bad boy
spectrum bruno a swagless peter parker
can't really train today
oh we don't hook up with bru no no no no
the hunky movie geek comrade do you like
watch bollywood movies obviously and the
other hunky movie geek kareem come with
me if you want to live what i've always
wanted to say that two hunky movie geeks
in one show
sure
and of course back at home is kamala's
doting mother who starts out not
trusting her at all no i don't trust you
but after her daughter keeps
disappearing in foreign countries for
hours at a time totally learns her
lesson and we trust her right oh that
makes sense
so enjoy a show disney clearly didn't
believe in or they wouldn't have buried
the first three episodes under obi-wan
which is a shame because the directors
made it look cool it's an american show
that's not full of evil muslims for a
change and oh by the way it officially
brings mutants into the mcu there's
something different
in your genes like a mutation
come for the origins of x-men stay for
the origins of pakistan we must go back
to a pivotal moment in the indian
struggle for independence
starring
the fantastic nor
marty mcshy
don't tell mom the super power spread
yeah i've got a girlfriend she's another
dimension though you wouldn't know her
kareem abdul dagar
another mcu nakia how we run out of
character names already
mad about yusuf diver and cleary damage
control oh i get it the bad guys are dc
quentin tarantino somebody stole my
shoes that joke again we are trying to
drop the name nightlight that's a bad
name it just sounds like it's for
five-year-olds red daggers
what are you gonna have pakistani boy
band and when you know you're really in
trouble
you're not going anywhere i know this is
the worst possible time to ask but
kamala khan
you know after watching this in rr last
month i think we can all agree on one
thing
nobody on earth likes the british
this episode was presented by ikea start
your heroic higher ed journey at ikea
usa.com back to college
it's days like these that i curse the
chinese for inventing gunpowder
it's always say this epic voiceover guy
and never how is epic voiceover guy oh
thanks i'm doing okay